[Applaudissements]
mais rien n'avait rien
paris
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour dans toutes vos
potes merci d'être avec nous les cherry
et je me demande si on va pas tout
filmer ce qui se passe pendant les pubs
parce que vous disent quelque chose on
est en direct il s'est passé quelque
chose sur ce plateau
il ya un instant juste sur moi ce qu'on
peut faire un plan sur quelqu'un
[Rires]
jean luc est ce que vous pouvez
expliquer ce qui s'est passé on avait on
a un arc et des flèches et donc c'est
franchement c'est pas de moi non
jean-luc effet que c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est que bah c'est la faute des
dirigeants de des huit avant tout parce
que s'il n'avait pas fait encore games
mais plutôt la petite maison dans la
prairie on n'en serait pas là mais ça
n'a pas en bien c'est donc il s'est dit
tiens
est ce que quelqu'un pourrait mettre une
bouteille sur sa tête oui évidemment il
a un qui accepte et tu comprends pas le
projet les images on avait six matches
regardez ça c'est alors c'était tout à
l'heure c'est égard nascar regarder et
donc voila vous au lit donc ça ça aurait
pu s'arrêter là
[Applaudissements]
mais rien n'avait rien la douleur on est
en train de comprendre qu'il voulait lui
viser la gueule des pétards et comme il
est une bouteille celle avec ses 10 ans
on va faire plus fort je vais faire
tomber la bouteille qui est pas sur ta
tête pascal et plus bouté sur sa tête et
vous ce qui devait arriver confiance et
ils doivent viser le front des fonds
mécontents en plus bas regarder et ne
fait pas que c'est bon je ne prête pas
que nous sommes aujourd'hui douzième
corps malade moi aussi il est bon
camarade parce que il est bon camarade y
prend la flèche dans la gueule j'étais à
côté il se tenait il avait mal et au
lieu de se plaindre il a fait quelques
lycées relevé quand même comment tu as
fait pour toucher la bouteille ouais
c'est ça la france d'aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça qu'on la balle